and first six topics be discussed
tomorrow under the heading Sahor andar.
So that'll be very interesting. Then
we've got the last 13 topics that you've
annunciated. Of course they will be
discussed in the coming days from the
9th until the 20th of Ramadan and the
middle topics that you've discussed. We
will now take them on as importance
right now. So Dr. Zakia the first topic
we need to discuss today is how can one
understand generosity in terms of
Ramadan. What are the acts of generosity
that you would recommend a Muslim to be
involved in?
>> A person should always be generous
throughout his life. But during Ramadan
he should be more generous. It should
reach its peak. And there are various
ways a person can be generous. For
example, one thing which normally people
think about generosity is helping people
with money. But that is not the only act
of generosity. That is one of the acts
of generosity. Helping someone with your
money.
>> The other act of generosity is that if
you share your knowledge, if you guide
someone, do islav someone or do da the
non-Muslims. Even this generosity, you
help him with your knowledge. The other
act of generosity is maybe you may help
them with your physical strength in
doing some work or maybe lifting
something. Even that's act of
generosity. Any good deed is an act of
generosity. For example, you may be in a
position. Being in that position, the
job you're doing, you may be able to
help someone in fulfilling his need.
Even that's an act of generosity. So all
these come under the acts of generosity.
And the hadith of a prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam it's
mentioned in say Bkari volume number one
in the book of revelation had number
five. It is said that Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he was the
most generous of all the people and
during the month of Ramadan his
generosity used to reach the peak and
archangel Gabriel used to visit him
during the month of Ramadan and used to
rehearse the Quran and it is said that
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
was more generous than the strong
uncontrollable wind he was the peak of
generosity. Further beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said it's
mesh had ofidi had number 3233
where it is said that there will be
rooms in paradise where you can see
inside the room from the outside and you
can see the outside from inside and
these rooms will be prepared for those
people who are generous and who help the
poor people those who fast
regularly and those who pray at night.
So these are special rooms prepared for
those people in paradise. Further
there's a hadith say mentioned innima
had number 1746 where our beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that any person who feeds the person who
has fasted he will get the reward of the
person who he has said who has been
fasting without diminishing the reward
of the person who was fasting.
Therefore, it shows that we should
encourage people to feed other people.
All these are acts of generosity.
>> Subhan Allah. I hope and pray that we
can be as generous as
suallam in this month. Inshallah.